hello everyone from time to time I write
something when there's something
particularly complex happening and I
have to get my thoughts and close formal
order and so I did that this week I
wrote an article for the telegraph I'm
going to read it
here it's called I'm pr- Muslim but
anti-
Thug over the past few years I've
engaged in a continual dialogue with
people across the spectrum of Islam from
aan hery Ali who left her religious
upbringing behind through moderates such
as Mustafa akul and Hamza yussef and
with foray into the more conservative
side with Muhammad hijab for example a
rather temperamental young Muslim not
without his influence in the
UK I have done this because I believe
that Jews Christians and Muslims share
more in common than in division and
because I know that since there is no
such thing as a world without religion
we all must do what is best with what we
have been
bequeathed I find myself in some
arguably serious online trouble this
week nonetheless although I realize I'm
far from alone in this because I
indicated my desire that the authorities
in Israel give the terrorists who
invaded their land and tortured and
killed their citizens the hell that they
most truly
deserve how could I say such a thing
while simultaneously m maining my desire
for rosma between the peoples of the
abrahamic
tradition let us begin that discussion
by rendering unto Caesar what is
Caesar's and unto God what is
Gods the attack on Israel last week by
the monsters of Hamas occurred as far as
I am concerned not because Muslims and
Jews must by religious
necessity be at each other's
throats but because Iran a country run
by Thugs and deem so even by its own
people has become very concerned that
the rulers of Saudi Arabia will continue
in their laudable attempts to formulate
a productive peace with Israel four Arab
countries recently signed the Abraham
Accords a trump era initiative that
should have garnered that exident for
all his manifold faults a Nobel Peace
Prize at least in a world where the of
Barack Obama were deemed worthy of such
an
honor behind the Arab signatories who
were essentially the United Arab
Emirates Bahrain Morocco and Sudan stood
the Saudis without whose tacd agreement
no such steps would have been taken and
everyone knew it Joe Biden and the
Democrats had a historic and
unparalleled opportunity to bring the
Saudis into the fold soon after they
took power from Trump
instead demonstrating an almost
miraculous
shortsightedness they alienated that
sometimes Troublesome Middle Eastern
power almost immediately after adopting
office choosing instead of Peace the
opportunity to deny to the previous
president of the United States any of
the honor he most truly deserved for his
revolutionary
breakthrough one that had been deemed
utterly impossible by the blinkered
fools who ruled the state department for
decades to say it again the Saudis would
have come aboard the great ship of the
Abraham Accords two years ago had Biden
seized the opportunity
instead he and his fellow Democrats
downplayed the significance of the Trump
administration's Cardinal achievement
just to score the cheapest and most
expensive of political points and here
we are again in consequence drowning in
the blood of many Israeli and
Palestinian
alike despite being snubbed in a truly
provocative Manner and their consequent
and Justified anger remember the Saudi
unwillingness to provide the US with
additional oil when Biden asked remember
their recent flirtation with
China the Saudi leaders have been
strongly considering the continuation
and extension of the Abra peace
process in
Consequence the totalitarian mulas of
Iran have been driven to desperation
knowing full well that such an agreement
would undermine and isolate them
fatally this is the same Iran by the way
that the Democrats under Biden have
utterly failed to resist and control
continuing a pattern wellestablished by
the aforementioned Nobel Laureate Obama
and what have Iran is it a shining star
in the Islamic firmament or is it a
country Hagrid by a pathologically
self-serving criminal kleptocracy
religious in name
only let's turn to psychology for a
moment to answer that
question there is a form of
Psychopathology well detailed in recent
years the veritable place where
psychological instability Meets Evil
itself the personality features that are
part and parcel of that danger to
integrated psyche and state alike first
acquired the nomenclature of dark
Triad a combination of
melanism instrumental manipulativeness
and deceit
narcissism inflated false self-esteem
and desire for unearned attention and
status and psychopathy a malignant
mixture of criminal propensity
callousness and parasitism the dark
Triad traits were identified and
measured by intellectual descendants of
the Canadian Dr Robert hair who spent
his life assessing and endeavoring to
understand the worst of the habitual
criminals responsible not only for the
most barbaric and cruel of misdemeanors
but also for the vast majority of
criminal acts the famous Paro principle
of unequal distribution of talent and
acquisition applies to the underworld as
well just as one 1% of the world's
inhabitants hold something approximating
70% of the wealth so 1% of the criminals
commit 70% of the
crimes but all that's not bad enough bad
as it is more recent investigators of
the structure of the darkest of
temperamental propensities found it
necessary to add an extra Dimension to
the measurement
Matrix
sadism positive Delight in the suffering
of others the more unnecessary and
gratuitous the better so now we have the
dark
tetrad dark tetrad types fit well into
what is known as cluster B of the
personality
disorders which also includes such
Delights as antisocial personality
disorder borderline personality disorder
the female equivalent of the criminal
tendency hisonic personal disorder also
mostly female and narcissistic
personality disorder those who manifest
cluster b symptomatology or sins have in
addition to their other psychologically
and socially dangerous Tendencies the
proclivity to claim positive virtue or
outright victim status while pursuing
their utterly self-serving grandiose and
destructive
claims the cluster beat types lie cheat
steal gossip reputation Savage brag
claim credit where none is due and
distribute blame to everyone but
themselves all the while pursuing
nothing but their own immediate immature
hedonistic self-gratification all the
while trumpeting their moral virtue and
or brandishing their identity as
unfairly oppressed Innocents when they
organize and this happens from time to
time they threaten the Integrity of the
entire Society within which they operate
hoping to light everything of flame and
dance orgiastic in the
runes this happened after the French
Revolution it happened in Soviet Russia
it happened in Nazi Germany it's
happening now in the west with the rise
of the woke it's something markedly
facilitated by the power accessibility
and irresponsibility of social media
which allows for cluster B misbehavior
to propagate with none of the usual real
world
consequences and we haven't plunged far
enough into the abyss yet think for a
moment use your imagination for evil if
you dare if you were hellbent on doing
nothing but maximizing your own
resentful narrowly self- serving
juvenile pleasure hoping as well to do
maximal harm along the way to anyone
skilled and conscientious enough to have
deserved a just reward in what guise
would you cloak
yourself if you were the least bit
treacherously wise you would adopt a
religious cover how better to camouflage
yourself than in the Robes of all that
is traditional just merciful and
ethical that is less effective in the
West Post death of God in consequence of
the collapse of religious Authority so
here the dark tetrad types portray
themselves as the very avatars of
compassion we're for the
downtrodden because we can then in good
conscience punish the deservedly
successful we're for diversity because
an ethical Unity stands against our
depredations wherefor inclusivity
because our fetishes and kings
demand their full expression and to hell
with everyone else we're for Equity
because Merit is our sworn
enemy ask yourself this too how else are
you to explain the staggeringly
incomprehensible spectacle of for
example queers for
Palestine perhaps the most egregious
example of the Union of the desire by
progressives to tear down everything in
the west that is worthy even at the cost
of formulating an alliance that would in
an instant be suicidal if it ever made
itself
manifest and for those Muslims thinking
that it's the evil Jews trademark
registered is Iran your idea of a worthy
Islamic State the very Iran whose
citizens Muslims all have been on the
brink of Revolution against their
Psychopathic Masters for more than a
year and dreaming about it for much
longer than that the very whose
hypothetically religious leaders have to
oppress their own women because that's
the only way they can control those upid
sufficiently to have a go at them the
Iran who has in recent weeks decided to
Rattle the chains of their Hamas dogs
stating in the background explicitly or
implicitly unleash the crest of your
minions send them to Israel to do their
worst the Jews will respond as they must
turn the opinion of the Arab world
against the Hebrews before we lose our
grip and if that means that the
Palestinians unite everyone reasonable
in the world against them at their great
cost so be it and has that not happened
Muslims ask yourself this who in the
west has Allied themselves with the
hypothetical cause of the oppressed
Palestinians in the days since the Hamas
invasion University students demented by
the same idiot left radical professors
who have destroyed Academia the former
president of Harvard University itself
Lawrence Summers said as much last
week who else
marxists whose hatred for Islam exceeds
anything that the most committed peral
fundamentalist Christian or Jew might
muster remind me once more what is it
that the opiate of the masses Muslims
what is regarded as the essential and
absolute enemy of the Communist
Utopia nothing but the very religious
practice you share with your abrahamic
brothers who else bringing up the rear
the increasingly delusional alphabet
Brigade The LGBT 2s SL L QQ Etc
Community foolish and blind enough to
assume that commonality of hypothetic
oppression is enough to unite it somehow
with the mulas of Tran and the gangsters
of Hamas dark tetrad types all who would
have their blue and pink heads on a Pike
in the street in a moment if they were
only granted the opportunity useful
idiots this is useful idiocy on a scale
undreamed of by the most extreme of
leninists and maoists alike and what if
Israel as an oppressor State well the
Palestinians who live in Israel proper
are certainly a lot better off by any
standard than the Palestinians who live
in Gaza despite the fortune that has
been sent to that blighted area all of
which for all intents and purposes has
been funneled into the secret and not so
secret bank accounts of the dark tetrad
religious leaders who parade their lying
virtues so
successfully it was CBC News itself
that announced in 2003 that Yasser
Arafat had squirrel away $1 billion in
his hidden
portfolios anyone who doesn't think the
same thing is happening now and that
goes for Ukraine too folks is a fool
whose blindness is leading them into the
proverbial
pit tell me this honestly angry Muslims
desirous of genuinely practicing your
faith do you really think you have
anything in common with those who have
aligned themselves with you in the West
in the past week are those the Brave and
forthright comrades in arm whose support
LEDs Credence to the Eternal and
endlessly manipulable Muslim against Jew
story and tell me again how that
Alliance is better for your faith and
your people than recognition of your
abrahamic commonality with the
Christians and present day descendants
of the ancient Hebrews and tell me too
how the decentralized structure of your
religion admirable in so many regards
protects it against capture under
situations of duress by the bloody
Psychopaths who make a faith nothing but
a front for criminal evil I'm not saying
we're any better in the west our
susceptibility to the blandishments of
the postmodern Marxist dark tetrad mob
is a weakness of equivalent danger but
it's your people taking Central stage
right now and your people who have to
make a wise decision
or else and it's a big or
else the Saudis and the other SES of the
Abraham Accords have a stark choice in
front of them as do the distributed in
various people of the Islamic World they
and you can allow the thugs particularly
those in Iran and Palestine to Triumph
in their propagandistic efforts to prop
up their own dismal miserable and
tyrannical States they and you can in
consequence battle the new peace treaty
signed with Israel forego all the
obvious benefits for the Muslim World
offered by that agreement and to acques
to continued rule by the crest of
Hypocrites misusing faith in the worst
possible of ways what is the famed
second commandment of
Moses do not use God's name in vain what
does that mean it does not mean do not
swear or if it does that is its most
trivial warning it means much more
fundamentally do not attribute to
yourself the virtue of the Divine when
acting on your own behalf let alone when
acting in the thrall of the forces of
Darkness
themselves this sentiment is reinforced
at least three times by Christ himself
in the gospels first when he says and
when thou prayest Thou shalt not be as
the Hypocrites are for they love to pray
standing in the C ogu and in the corners
of the streets that they may be seen of
men second pointing to the moral hazard
in doing good works other than privately
but when thou doest alms let not thy
left hand know what thy right hand doeth
and third when he says not everyone that
saith unto me Lord Lord shall enter into
the kingdom of heaven but he that doeth
the will of My Father which is in
heaven once again again the mere claim
that it is religious conviction that
motivates personal action is no proof
whatsoever that such is the
case it is very difficult to aim upward
in Alliance with the spirit that wishes
everything well and in keeping with the
truth it is a path rif with moral hazard
and the public display of virtue
including the adoption of high church or
mosque or synagogue position is not any
guarantee that the god claimed to be
present is in fact there quite the
contrary all too
often the Saudis and you in the Muslim
World more generally could instead
remove the beam from your eyes as we
should equally in the west see what is
so starkly manifesting itself in the
world turn away from the terrible
tempting path of righteous destruction
continue the work already begun in
uniting the people of the book and
thereby bring a productive generous wise
and Lasting peace to this bited but
still not yet doomed and even
potentially wonderful green and blue orb
we need a transcendental access to
revolve around to move us Beyond a
blinkered materialism to protect us
against a foolish populism and to lift
up our eyes to the Eternal Heaven
beckoning above us in the west we have
that for all the faults of the followers
of the Creeds and even with the Creed
themselves as currently understood in
the form of Islam Christianity and
Judaism we need our abrahamic faith lest
the hedonistic pagans and worse Prevail
and we need to stand United behind it
and that is why I'm pr- Muslim but anti
Thug and if you are a true follower of
Ella that is the decision that is
incumbent upon you in equal measure and
that goes as well for the Christians and
the
Jews